this morning we are launching a new
series called looking forward to 2021
it's a wide-ranging look at what we can
expect next year
everything from politics to education
and travel
in less than a month joe biden will be
sworn in as the 46th president of the
united states he will
enter the white house during an
unprecedented time of political
divisions
and a raging pandemic joining us now are
cbs news political contributors robbie
mook
and terry sullivan robbie was the
presidential campaign manager for
hillary clinton in 2016
and terry manor senator marco rubio's
presidential campaign
that very same year good morning good to
see you both morning
all right robin let me start with you
despite the pandemic a divided nation
and voters who incorrectly claim an
illegitimate election
you say that president-elect biden once
he
is inaugurated should focus on the
economy explain that reasoning
yeah absolutely you know during the
campaign this was really about big
things
light versus dark dividing the nation
versus bringing it together but the fact
of the matter is
when president biden comes into office
all the things you talked about are
going to be there
um it's going to be a very divisive
environment and it's going to be
incumbent on him to focus like a laser
on getting the economy uh working for
people and look that's going to be a
fight we're already talking today about
a vote uh to increase those stimulus
payments
to two thousand dollars um and you know
his team has so far projected that so i
think that's the plan
um but he's got to start to demonstrate
that he has a plan that's about people's
lives
that you know transitioning from again
this this campaign that was about
much bigger symbolic uh matters
i want to bring terry in here in his
final weeks in office the president went
against congressional republicans
the same republicans who just a few
weeks ago over 100 of them supported
the president when it came to
challenging some of those
election results what does that say
about where the republican party is
right now and what do you think the
president should be prioritizing
well i think the president should
prioritize his golf game at the moment
him staying out of the politics of it or
the more importantly the policy of it is
a good thing
look the republicans in congress
put together the best kind of plan they
possibly could
after nancy pelosi obstructing it for so
long and playing politics but keeping it
from from coming to a vote before the
election she didn't want to give
republicans
or donald trump the benefit and
and now she finally agreed to and passed
it as bragging about a bill that was
extremely similar to what she said would
no way pass
in october so i think republicans need
to focus on policy this is a rebuilding
time for them
they need to focus on the fundamentals
of what it means to be a conservative
so robbie the president-elect campaigned
as a
moderate democrat uh there are some who
criticize
uh president-elect biden who are
democrats and say look the
the political landscape that the
president-elect knew as a senator
doesn't exist anymore
he's going to have to work with for
example members of the progressive wing
of the democratic party he's seen some
pushback from them
how does he do that delicate dance that
balance between
the needs of the country but also
appeasing his progressive
wing well he's doing that delegate uh
dance now you know we've seen he's had
to manage a number of opinions and a
number of different ways of the party in
terms of putting together his cabinet
and it is a historically diverse cabinet
uh both in terms of representation of of
you know different groups but also
different ideologies you know i think
the other thing
uh to keep in mind here is uh
right away there's gonna be an
engagement with the republican senate
and with mitch mcconnell
so everybody's gonna be fighting on the
same team like i said there's a vote
today
uh to increase these payments from 600
to 2000
uh dollars um and there are going to be
more fights like that that do
unify the party and so i think in some
ways having divided government
helps to keep everybody focused on the
game to keep the party unified
in a way that just wouldn't be possible
if democrats could do
whatever they want sorry robbie you
mentioned
the cabinet the president-elect has
filled his cabinet
with a lot of obama administration folks
why
well in a lot of new people too look
this always happens when the obama
cabinet was coming together
there were a lot of clinton people in
there you have to bring in people with
experience that's one of the things that
biden ran on
was he wanted competent people who could
handle the coveted crisis for example
but we're seeing uh new folks as well um
in a number of posts you know p buddha
judge is a great example of that someone
who
who came along after the obama
administration was over
and i think you'll see more as the
cabinet fills out in its entirety they
haven't even named all the
the positions yet terry very quickly if
you could tell me what impact if any do
you think the president's claims of
voter fraud will have on the
uh senate runoffs in georgia
well first of all i'd like to point out
and thank robbie for his confidence that
republicans are going to retain the
senate and thus win those
seats when he talks about divided
government so so thanks for being on our
team
uh robbie i appreciate that um look
you know i don't know that the voter
fraud issue is going to play nearly as
much of a role as some of these
these other theatrics that have happened
with uh
you know after after those two senators
were very loyal to him and issued a
statement supporting
president trump he pulled the rug out
from underneath him on voting for this
uh this legislation they literally had
commercials in the can ready to go to
take credit
for this stimulus and he's out there on
twitter
saying how awful an abomination it is so
i think i think that is going to do far
greater damage
to the republican people republican
senate candidates there
yeah he's uh president said he's going
to travel to georgia to help bolster
uh their aspirations uh robbie mook
terry sullivan as always
we appreciate it guys thank you very
much thank you